willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung der
ethik der digitalität heute befassen wir
uns mit dem thema ethik der künstlichen
intelligenz und robotik
allerdings ist es erst der erste teil
von drei sitzungen es folgen noch zwei
die sich damit befassen werden weil
dieses thema so weit ist das kann man so
viel dazu sagen und es ist auch so
aktuell
liegt der künstliche intelligenz könnte
man es nennen künstliche intelligenz ist
nicht nur aber eben auch ein phänomen
der digitalisierung vielleicht eines der
prominentesten phänomene der
digitalisierung man kann darüber
diskutieren ob künstliche intelligenz
nicht auch schon vor dieser technik der
digitalisierung existierte
mit rechenmaschinen usw da kann man auch
wieder fragen waren diese
rechenmaschinen nicht auch schon
irgendwie digital zu nennen riesen frage
wir konzentrieren uns hier nur auf die
digitalen also elektrisch mit strom
betriebenen maschinen
und wir haben jetzt hier einige fragen
die wir klären sollten bevor wir uns mit
der idee der künste intelligenz befassen
so ist es ja auch mit dem internet
gewesen dass wir in der letzten sitzung
diskutiert hat und dann mache ich oben
rechts den link ein auch da sollten wir
uns erst überlegen was ist eigentlich
das internet bevor wir uns damit der
ethik des internets befassen ist das
internet nur ein konsum medium ja dann
stellen sich andré ethische fragen als
wenn ich das internet als einen
handlungsraum sehe oder irgendwie als
ein metaversum das ist hängt also ganz
entschieden davon ab wie wir diese
phänomene die wir hier behandeln im
rahmen der ethik der digitalität also
das internet künstliche intelligenz aber
auch computerspiele virtuelle realität
sie wird ihn überhaupt bestimmen und
jetzt können wir uns folgende fragen
stellen ist künstliche intelligenz ein
subjekt kann
künstliche intelligenz handeln besitzt
künstliche intelligenz intentional i tät
intensität bedeutet gerichtet hat
mentale absichten wünsche alles das was
eine richtung anzeigt was auf einen
geist schließen lässt ja ist künstliche
intelligenz autonom häufig spricht man
von autonomen maschinen
das sind fragen und wir haben jetzt uns
heute einen text von katrin bislang
vorgenommen zu maschinen ethik und auch
da haben wir uns einige fragen überlegt
was es der gegenstand der maschinen
ethik was bedeutet künstliche
intelligenz worin besteht der
unterschied zwischen künstlicher
intelligenz als symbol verarbeitung und
künstlicher intelligenz als künstliche
neuronale netze das ist wichtig weil
heutzutage spricht man wenn man von ki
spricht meistens für diesen künstlichen
neuronalen netzen oder diesen die
burning die symbol verarbeitung ist ihr
die ältere form von künstlicher
intelligenz und die beiden unterscheiden
sich schon und wir müssen immer
überlegen von welcher form sprechen wir
hier worin besteht die ethische
problematik von verhaltensbasierte bzw
verkörpert ak ii das ist eben eine ganz
neue forschungsrichtung auf die katrin
bisserl hingewiesen hat ja das ist
dieses besagte buch sehr zu empfehlen
grundfragen der maschine ethik gibt gute
einführen und sie sagt jetzt folgendes
je intelligenter und autonome maschinen
werden desto größer ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie in
situationen geraten die ihnen moralische
entscheidungen abverlangen doch können
maschinen überhaupt moralisch handeln
und sollen sie es wie baut man einen
moralischen maschine fragen wie diesen
beschäftigt sich die maschinen ethik ein
neues forschungsgebiet an der
schnittstelle von philosophie informiert
informatik und partikel die maschine
ethik sagt kathrin wieland weiter
unterscheidet sich von anderen form der
technik tätig war gegenstand die
entwicklung einer ethik für maschinen im
gegensatz zu einer ethik für menschen im
umgang mit maschinen ist es geht nicht
nur um die frage wie die menschen mit
einer bestimmten technologie
beispielsweise atomkraft aus moralischer
sicht umgehen sollten das ziel ist
vielmehr darüber nachzudenken ob und wie
man mensch maschinen konstruieren kann
ihr selbst moralische entscheidung
treffen und umsetzen können und ob man
dies tun sagt hat ein bisserl horn
argumentiert jetzt das jetzt nicht um
unser verhältnis zu den maschinen geht
es um die maschinen selbst hier möchte
ich etwas kritisch ein bin ich glaube um
die maschinen selbst kann es in einer e
die knie gehen wo menschen im spiel sind
es geht immer um unser verhältnis zu
diesen masken also wir bekommen unser
verhältnis gar nicht heraus zu diesen
maschinen andere es sei denn wir würden
diesen maschinen uns vorstellen wie
autonome subjekte die völlig unabhängig
von uns entscheiden können aber da gibt
es einige probleme und da wird man auch
dann im rahmen des heutigen seminars
noch näher darauf eingehen ich möchte
trotzdem noch ein paar zitate hier
vorlesen weil sie sehr instruktiv sind
das buch sagt zu beginn auf seite 8
weiter dieses thema maschine ethik ist
in der geschichte der ethik neue weil es
erstmals mit der entstehung des
computers überhaupt dann wird den
bereich des möglichen gerückt ist man
muss dazu sagen die gedanken und ja auch
philosophien zu maschinen nicht
menschlichen
künstlichen subjekten wenn man so will
sind natürlich schon älter
denken sie an frankenstein wo auch ein
künstlicher mensch erschaffen wird er
irgendwie eine maschine ist dann aber
plötzlich autonom wird und auch
gefährlich wird also die gedanken sind
jedenfalls eher älter aber sie kommen
jetzt erstmals wirklich in die den
horizont des möglichen die rasante
entwicklung der künstlichen intelligenz
im letzten jahrzehnt beflügelte die
maschinen ethik und macht sie zugleich
unabdingbar damit diese technologische
entwicklung segensreich verläuft man
spricht analog zur artificial
intelligence auch von otto fischer
morality während erstere das ziel hat
intelligentes verhalten zu modellieren
und zu simulieren gibt es letzterer
darum künstliche systeme mit der
fähigkeit zur moralischen entscheiden
und handeln auszustatten sie sehen es
hin ganz entschieden davon ab können
künstliche systeme wirklich handeln oder
simulieren sie nur handeln das ist jetzt
die grundhaltung zwischen simulation und
realisation oder duplikation gekommen
gleich darauf schon sir zu sprechen der
von publikationen dann spricht wenn es
um maschinen geht die nicht nur
moralische entscheidung simulieren
sondern auch wirklich verziehen bei mir
bestand die maschinen ethik zu unrecht
im verdacht des science fiction doch
schon einst so simple maschine wie ein
staubsauger roboter steht vom
moralischen entscheiden soll ein
marienkäfer einfach ein saugen oder soll
er eben verscheuchen bzw umfahren und
wie sieht es mit einer spinne was soll
er sie töten oder ebenfalls verschoben
an solche reporter ist in einem
minimalen sind autonom bei einem
unterschied zu einem konventionellen
staubsauger nicht von einem menschen
geführt wird die entscheidung ist
moralisch weil sie darauf abzielt ob man
tiere zur einigung zwischen töten darf
gewöhnliche staubsaugerroboter besitzen
allerdings noch nicht die fähigkeit eine
solche entscheidung zu treffen es gibt
jedoch erste ansätze eine um ein ethik
modul erweiterte version des populären
modells umbau zu schaffen die das leben
von den säcken berücksichtigt der
prototyp ist mit einem optionalen körper
dafür können ausgestattet
jetzt ist hier die these solche roboter
solche staubsauger roboter sind deswegen
autonomen nennen zu nehmen auch wenn nur
in einem minimalen sinne wie katrin
wissen hier sagt weil sie nicht von
menschen geführt wer hier minimal gute
nun also der mensch steht nicht hinter
jeder aktion dieses roboter sollen der
roboter bekommt gewissermaßen freihand
oder auslauf wo auch immer in der küche
flur und der mensch muss nicht permanent
intervenieren oder in jeder situation
neu entscheiden jetzt stellt sich die
frage können roboter wirklich
entscheiden oder sind die entscheidungen
nicht irgendwie schon ein programmiert
dass man sagt wenn dann b
und dann wäre ja am ende doch wieder der
mensch oder die programmiererin der
programmierer das unternehmen autonomen
dafür verantwortlich und würde ihn eben
doch führen den roboter bin auch nicht
direkt sondern vermitteln über viele
schritte viele programmierschritte und
weitere damit liegen dass dir die
entscheidende frage wie wir diese
autonomie auch wenn sie nur minimal ist
verstehen sollen bei robotern die
komplexe die einsatzbereiche autonome
systeme sind desto anspruchsvoller
werden die moralischen entscheidungen
die sie treffen müssen dies zeigt sich
beispielsweise ein pflegesystem kriegs
robotern und autonomen fahrzeugen die
drei paradigmatischen anwendungsfeldern
der maschine ethik die auch in diesem
buch behandelt werden in allen drei
bereichen stehen autonome systeme für
grundlegende moralische entscheidungen
in dem es manchmal sogar um leben und
tod von menschen geht kann man maschinen
solche entscheidungen überlassen darf
man ist oder sollte man es gab hier
stellt sich die frage welche art von
entscheidung hat ein solcher und bottel
beharrt oder hatte überhaupt nicht
scheitern die muss man ganz arg
aufpassen wenn man solche begriffe
verwendet die eigentlich auf menschliche
subjekte bezogen sind wenn man die jetzt
überträgt auf maschinen und
ein weiteres detail wie wichtig dieses
thema maschine ethik ist zeigt sich auch
an der großen aufmerksamkeit die
mögliche dilemma situation beim
autonomen fahren einer breiteren
öffentlichkeit erhalten haben was ist
wenn ein autonomes fahrzeug
ausschließlich die möglichkeit hat
wieder einen menschen am ende seines
lebens oder ein kleines kind zu töten
was wenn es nur durch fünf dadurch fünf
menschenleben retten kann dass es eine
auf dem gehweg stehende person anfährt
ist ein besonderer schutz für die
insassen moralisch legitim bekommt den
anderen verkehrsteilnehmern von
moralischen standpunkt mehr gewicht zu
dass es wieder dieses tolle problem
entscheidungssituation und vergibt
könnte man meinen sehen sich auch
intelligente systeme gestellt wie zb
autonome fahrzeug autonom jetzt wieder
in anführungsstrichen
[Musik]
und jetzt gibt kaffee missel horn auf
den unterschied zwischen
drei verschiedenen formen von
intelligenz ein es gibt einmal symbol
verarbeitende künstliche intelligenz
dann gibt es die künstlichen neuronalen
netze das sind häufig die dinge die wir
mit autonomie in verbindung stehen und
mit entscheiden und dann gibt es
neuerdings auch noch verkörperte
künstliche intelligenz die dann noch
stärker in richtung robotik geht
künstliche neuronale netze sagt sie
bilden nicht in die einzige alternative
zum klassischen symbol verarbeitung spa
raten also symbol verarbeitung ist das
traditionelle künstliche intelligenz
denken wo eben nur symbole manipuliert
werden das ist die touring maschine das
geht in diese richtung der
rechenmaschinen am da werden symbole
manipuliert aber es wird eigentlich
nichts gelernt und gelernt wird eben
erst von diesen systemen durch die
neuronalen netze in den 80er jahren kam
ein neuer ansatz und spielt er unter den
begriff der welt im bodytel oder
verhaltensbasierte kann bekannt wurde
während der comic zionismus kollektion
ismus ist jetzt bekommen noch genauer
drauf die auffassung der künstlichen
neuronalen netze also der verbindungs
kann während der kollektion es muss den
fehler des klassischen paradigmas das
klassische paradigma ist die symbol
verarbeitung die symbol manipulation
intelligenz gänzlich unabhängig von der
beschaffenheit des menschlichen körpers
zu betrachten der kondition ismus
orientiert sich am menschlichen gehirn
an diesen neuronen des neuronalen netze
fordert die verhaltensbasierte ki auch
den körper und seine umwelt mit
einzubeziehen die beiden zentralen
schlag wurde die diesen ansatz
charakterisieren sind daher verkörperung
konstituiert hat der kognition
vordergrund stehen nun nicht mehr
anspruchsvolle geistige leistung sondern
sensomotorischen fähigkeiten über die
auch verhaltens mesic einfache
organismen wie insekten verfügen dieser
ansatz bleibt folgerichtig nicht bei
computermodell stehen sondern führt zum
bau von robotern über einen körper
sensoren und aktoren verfügen ziel ist
es systeme zu schaffen die die fähigkeit
haben ihre umwelt wahrzunehmen sich in
ihr zu bewegen und objekte zu
manipulieren so dass sie es nicht
erhalten und unter umstellt sogar
reproduzieren können hier sieht man
natürlich ganz klar hier steht der
gedanke des lebens im zentrum hier
versucht man lebendige systeme zu
entwickeln die sich fortpflanzen können
die sich auch regenerieren können
und die eben auch stoffwechsel
vielleicht sogar betreiben mit der
umwelt
ja das ist die frage ob es das überhaupt
geben kann als wir haben es mit 3 1 sind
es jetzt zu tun dem klassischen ansatz
ist die symbol verarbeiten bka die
manipuliert nur zeichen zeichen
manipulation das sind die ganz
traditionellen systeme dann gibt es
diesen etwas neueren ansatz der sich
schon etwas an unserem gehirn orientiert
natürlich immer noch sehr modellhaft mit
neuronen künstliche millionen das sind
die künstlichen neuronalen netze und
neuerdings gibt es die verkörperte
die versucht mit der umwelt zu
interagieren wo man eben auch die
kontexte noch stärker berücksichtigt
jetzt hatte ich schon ein bisschen was
gesagt zum symbol verarbeitenden
paradigma das ist allen touring und er
hat hier ein jahr 950 ein aufsatz
geschrieben computing machinery and
intelligence das ist ein klassischer
aufsatz und hier sieht man jetzt wie
dieses symbol verarbeitende kann
funktioniert er stellt sich die frage
wie man die frage kein machines sinkt
können maschinen zu verstehen hat und er
[Musik]
argumentiert er wie diese frage ob
maschinen denken können ersetzen sollten
durch die frage an der im national
digital computer switch virtuell in die
mädchen gang also gibt es
vorstellbare digitale computer die in
dem action game
erfolgreich wäre jetzt muss man
natürlich fragen was das mädchen geben
sie haben bestimmt schon mal diesen
turing test gehört was was verbirgt sich
dahinter ist ein gedankenexperiment das
habe ich jetzt aus wikipedia also es ist
so es gibt eine person ca
die soll jetzt
erkennen
ob hinter einer band oder wo auch immer
eine andere menschliche person oder ein
computer die wahrheit sagt also es geht
darum dass sich eine person zu einem
computer und einer wirklichen person
verhält auch wenn sie nicht weiß wer
jetzt der computern wer die person ist
und dieser computer soll vorgeben dass
er eine frau oder ein mann sei auch die
person b soll vorgeben eine frau oder
ein mann zu sein und dann muss jetzt die
person zu erraten wer recht es geht also
am ende darum kann die person sie von
dem computer überzeugt werden kann der
computer authentischer erscheinen in
seinen äußerungen die ausgetauscht
werden als die andere person bist also
ein ratespiel
und jetzt hat man da an kritik übten hat
gesagt das was hier gezeigt wird in
diesem touring game diesen militärischen
gb der computer soll letztendlich eine
wirkliche person notieren das ist
eigentlich
doch nur die juristen muss alle da wird
auch nicht wirklich intelligenz gezeigt
sondern da wird doch nur ja
äußerlichkeiten ausgetauscht hier wird
nicht möglich intelligenz exemplifiziert
es geht einfach nur darum dass dieser
computer täuschen kann aber in der
täuschung liegt auch noch nicht wirklich
eine intelligenz leistung ist also sehr
oberflächlich konnte man sagen und es
gibt nach wie vor die frage ob diese
station gehen wirklich funktioniert alan
turing hat in seinem aufsatz die these
vertreten dass im jahr
2000 nämlich genau 50 jahre nach diesen
aufsatz
dieses im ethischen game funktionieren
würde das also da diese computer die
raten die person überzeugen könnte er
sagt ein brief der der bau fügte jungs
time it will be possible to programm
computer unter storage capacity of the
nine also praktisch
einer
milliarde
template imitation games sowie der
winter will not have morden 7% chains of
making bereit identifikation after five
minutes of questions all das ist jetzt
eine sehr präzise angabe er glaubt eben
das nach fünf minuten
der die fragende person nicht mehr als
70 prozent wahrscheinlichkeit hat denn
die richtige instanz zu identifizieren
also computer wird hier sehr überzeugend
zahlen das glaubt er jetzt im jahr 2000
jahr kann man sich erkundigen wie es
aussieht gehen wird ja noch
weitergespielt mit
hotspots kann ein jackpot so
programmiert werden dass er uns ganz
überzeugen kann
nach fünf minuten immer noch also das
wäre die frage wie lange hält der ob das
durch gewissermaßen uns zu täuschen oder
täuschte uns überhaupt nicht sind
exemplifiziert er wirklich wirklich
intelligenz dupliziert er sie spannende
frage und
jetzt sagt er weiter in diesem sehr
wichtigen aufsatz die ritschel question
kehrmaschine sich ibfp training lässt
die services discussion and less
beliebte tappy nds entry to use of words
and general ken keen will have to watch
the throne will be able to speak auf
maschinen thinking without expecting to
be connected er sagt also
gegen ende des jahrhunderts also um das
jahr 2000 eher werden wir die frage ob
maschinen denken können nicht mehr so
betrachten als ob das sich dabei um ein
widerspruch an wert während da ein
anderes verständnis haben von maschinen
und ihre möglichen klicken ich denke im
jahr 2000 war das nicht so ganz der fall
aber im jahr 2020 schon mehr als er hat
sich vielleicht hier um 20 jahre
versetzt also heutzutage wie wir jetzt
ja auch anhand des seminars sehen wird
die frage ob computer denken nicht mehr
als absurd wahrgenommen man kann darüber
diskutieren
es gibt beispiele wie dieses jahr
spielen dieses schließer schachcomputer
der schadprogramme die menschliche
akteure der schauspielerin schachspieler
besiegen können sie kennen das beispiel
des brettspiels co auch eine ki er
mittlerweile den besten menschlichen
spieler betroffen hat also es ist nicht
mehr so trivial natürlich kann man sich
fragen ist denn schach spielen überhaupt
denken ist ingo denken handelt sich
dabei um eine form von denken oder mich
um eine sehr komplizierte form von ja
rechenoperation hat das kann man sich
immer fragen
muss man diskutieren jetzt haben wir
hier einen weiteren wichtigen denker auf
diesem feld nämlich johns höher der hat
ein buch geschrieben
kein computer fängt das ein kapitel in
seinem buch mainz brands
184 sie sehen die diskussion gibt schon
lange hier schon seid ja eigentlich seit
1950 gibt es natürlich auch schon länger
aber so nach in der nachkriegszeit kann
sie wirklich auf als die großrechner
entwickelt wurden und er sagt jetzt in
diesem aufsatz im syntax erlaubt ist nur
zwischen fassen ein text ein diebstahl
computer-software sdr computers heft bei
definition des centers erlauben hier ist
ganz wichtig die unterscheidung zwischen
syntax und semantik syntax ist einfach
nur die ordnung von symbolen also
eigentlich heißt sonntags dies das
nebeneinanderstellen sie kennen das auch
in der sprache des winters und die
grammatik gesundheit ist die wort
stellung wir müssen die worte angeordnet
werden wie dürfen sie angeordnet es geht
also um regeln der wort anordnung und
genauso kann man sorge um regeln der
zeichen manipulation und er sagt jetzt
nein mit regeln verzeichnet manipulation
können wir nicht bedeutung erlangen und
er sagt digitale computer sind
definitorischen
taktische maschinen die nur zeichen
manipulation von ihm aber die dadurch
eben nicht wirkliche bedeutung hervor
bahn der iss november das system kein
geld von textunes semantics sie kennen
vielleicht ist ein instrument das stammt
von john soll das ist also auch wiederum
ein gedankenexperiment wie bei allen
touring und da ist ganz ähnlich wie dies
im action game hier soll eben ein
computer gibt ein computer immer ein
richtiges zeichen aus die einer fragen
person die jetzt chinesisch lernen
möchte die richtige antwort geben
computer bekommt die regeln welche
zeichen herausgeben muss und die äußere
person menschliche person denkt dann
tatsächlich der computer versteht was
sie sagt aber er manipuliert nur zeichen
nach einer vorschrift er führt nur aus
nach einer regel und dieses ausführender
regeln würde jetzt soll sagen ist noch
nicht gleichbedeutend mit
sprachverständnis
ganz unten sagt der sinking is more than
just a matter of money plating jähnigen
des symbols den wolfs wenig 14 content
ins genannte content award mimin bei
mini also zeichnet manipulation nach
regeln das ist nichts was wirklich
bedeutung generieren kann deswegen so
seine these sind zumindest symbol
verarbeitende computer nicht intelligent
zu nennen weil intelligenz das ist so
implizit immer auch bedeutung
voraussetzt das kann man sich natürlich
fragen ja woher kommt denn die bedeutung
woher bekommen denn die medienfonds im
endcontent
einmal könnte sich jetzt hier fragen zum
beispiel durch austausch mit der
umgebung und in diese richtung geht dann
auch gleich der nächste einsatz nicht
vorstellen möchte er sagt noch eines
über die bedeutung talking about having
the same thing meinolf die simulation
simply relevant diese simulation also
die von symbol verarbeiten kann das sind
mehrere
technology ist auch werke der
kalkulation snakebyte computer
eines computers operations have to be
defined intakte clean desk awards für
links emotions and all the rest of that
involve morgens in texas features beide
mischen der computer ist unable to
public power von maybe the moment wie
das team schon hier ist bequem
publikation publication and simulation
simulation balver konzentriert apple
case also simulation sagte das können
die computer machen die können
simulieren zu denken diese ganzen
mentalen phänomene zu haben also
bewusstsein gedanken gefühle emotionen
das mentale phänomene die können sie
simulieren durch zeichen manipulation
aber sie können sie nicht publizieren
oder realisieren und das nennt er die
castingshow die schlüssel unterscheidet
es muss man sich natürlich fragen sind
alle computer sind alle maschinen im
sinne der symbol verarbeitenden computer
zu verstehen nicht aber er hat diese
entwicklung
damals noch nicht wirklich kennen lernen
können weil sie eben erst dieser zeit
sich entwickelt hat nämlich die
künstlichen neuronalen netzen hier ist
ein anderer philosoph sehr wichtig dass
robert dreyfuss und der hat ein
aufsatz geschrieben mit seinem bruder
der ein informatiker ist making am hain
börse smartlinx spray nautische
intelligence back at brands freuen
dieser aufsatz ist von
1984 oder in den 80er jahren erschienen
und eben stellt einen ganz neuen ansatz
dar
dreyfus ist allerdings ein großer
kritiker künstliche intelligenz er hat
sich sehr früh schon mit dieser frage
beschäftigt familientauglicher
intelligence von 1964 65 dann ein
weiteres buch bordcomputers can't do the
limits of artificial intelligence and
und hier noch einen weiteren ort
computers ilka du warst immer noch nicht
können kritik auf orte fischer riesen er
ist ein sehr großer kritiker künstliche
intelligenz muss dazu sagen es gibt eine
anekdote er war der erste mensch der
gegen einen schachprogramm verloren hat
also er wurde von einem sprachcomputer
besiegt natürlich kann man sich jetzt
zwar ist das ein zeichen dafür dass der
computer intelligenz hatte oder nur dass
er besser rechnen konnte
genau die ist das war das programm magix
667 dass er gegen ihn verloren hat
dieser aufsatz ist aus dem die 188 also
vier jahre später als dieses dieser
beitrag von jongleur und jetzt sagt er
hier folgendes also seine seinen ansatz
ist künstliche intelligenz sollte immer
situiert sein das geht schon ein
bisschen diese richtung im body
und sagt die ganzen mentalen phänomene
können wir nur durch nicht durch sowohl
verarbeitung erlangen sei nur durch
vernetzung tituliert hat er bezieht sich
hierbei auf heiliger und wittgenstein
die sind für ihn die vorbilder dieses
situierten denken sagt heiliger
wittenstein arbeit human beings
engagement holistic web
intelligence history motivierte person
services in die organistin kurt pick up
beide organisationen gehen kann
minimum unique von alles ist dort auf wo
norden ist die
international
university programm computer still have
a very long way to go selbst neuronale
netze die uns im gehirn nachempfunden
sind
sagt jetzt 34 selbst die
reichen nicht aus um
eben wirkliche menschliche intelligenz
zu platzieren zu simulieren schon die
intelligenz muss immer letztendlich
durch ein leben von dir zeit durch ein
organismus und der organismus ist nicht
nur sein ein isoliertes phänomen könnte
ist immer ein gebeten eine kultur die
größere kontext also bald wird solange
diese neuronalen netze nicht den
größeren kontext eingebunden sind werden
sie nie menschliche intelligenz
duplizieren können ja hier muss man
natürlich wieder sagen hier liegt der
annahme die auffassung zu grunde dass
künstliche intelligenz immer als ein
subjekt gefasst wird wie das menschliche
subjekt dass es überhaupt generell
gefragt sollten wir künstliche
intelligenz sei sie jetzt symbol
verarbeiten sei sie
im sinne des kollektion ismus hatte der
neuronalen netze oder sie sind der
verkörperten kalli müssen wir die allzu
deckte denken als maschinen oder können
wir sie nicht auch anders verstehen und
ich möchte hier im rahmen dieses
seminars für eine andere ansicht
plädieren und die auch zur diskussion
stellen also die frage ist die wie
sollen wir kari verstehen kay als
technik- oder technologie
schließen sich auch nicht gegenseitig
aus wir können mehrere auffassungen
vertreten kann ja als werkzeug
instrumente
als medium als vermittlungsinstanz
karriere als objekt oder maschine
als autonomes subjekt bzw autonome
maschine zur spricht kathrin bisschen
davon dann kommen jetzt neue auffassung
die mir persönlich sehr plausibel
erscheinen kann als prozess kann als
struktur und zum als erweiterung des
menschen und ihr werden mit der nächsten
sitzung darauf eingehen auf douglas
engelbart das ist auch ein
amerikanischen pionier der die these
vertritt wir sollten als erweiterungen
als augmented
intelligence verstehen und nicht als
subjekte oder irgendwelche autonomen
wesen die neben uns existieren also mir
sind so dann mache ich keinen hehl draus
sind diese letzten drei
positionen am sympathischsten
weil sie eben nicht in dieses problem
führen dass wir uns dann künste
intelligenz im sinne eines subjekts
denken müssen was uns irgendwie
entgegentritt zum ki wird als prozess
als struktur als eine erweiterung
unserer intelligenz leistung sichtbar
sie wird anwendbar sie wird vernetzt mit
anderen intelligenzleistungen es wird
durchs internet vernetzt aber wir haben
es hier nicht mit anderen objekten zu
tun aber das müssen wir diskutieren
jetzt gibt es traditionellerweise vier
problematische positionen mindestens
bezüglich kalli vielleicht sogar mehr
die möchte ich auch mal kurz vorstellen
vielleicht finden wir noch weitere
wir haben einerseits die ideologisierung
von calais im rahmen einer transformers
tisch futuro logischen silicon valley
ideologie das ist dann also der tanzform
annis muss auf den kommen wir auch noch
einen eigenen 16 zu sprechen diesem
semester der vertritt die auffassung
die wird irgendwann die weltherrschaft
an sich reißen und das ist auch gut also
die menschliche evolution führt dazu
dass sie dann am ende nicht nur
natürlich evolutionär ist und auch
technologisch revolutionär und am ende
kommt dann so ein supercomputer raus
dann gibt es die profis probleme eine
anthroposophie sierung von ki die diese
als eine lebendige person versteht
kathrin isselhorst ansatz geht etwas in
diese richtung weil sie ja davon spricht
dass die maschine eine bin auch nur eine
autonomie besitzen oder eine ganzkörper
es wäre eine andere profi sierung also
im sinne des menschen gedacht dann gibt
es aber auch eine entgegensetzte
auffassung die banalisierung der kalli
als bloßes hilfsmittel da würde ich
sagen dass eine technologische reduktion
um es gibt natürlich noch die
dramatisierung der ki die ist dann so
die gegenposition von einst die nämlich
sagt die maschinen werden immer
intelligenter
wir müssen aufpassen dass es eine gefahr
die müssen wir bekämpfen das ist also
die gegenposition zu eins weil die erste
position genau dasselbe annimmt dass die
ki intelligent wird aber die findet das
positiv und die vierte position die sie
das auch so dass es intelligente
maschinen gibt aber die sieht das sehr
negativ für davon an terminator denken
aber solche dinge also hier spielt ein
bild untergangsszenarien auch eine rolle
ich glaube dass wir uns zwischen 2 und 3
so ein bisschen verorten sollten 1 und 4
halte ich für zu spekulativ aber darüber
kann man diskutieren
ich denke so die die mitte liegt
irgendwo zwischen zwei und drei und wir
wollen darf man jetzt weiter diskutieren
dh wenn man jetzt von einer ethik der
künstlichen intelligenz sprechen dann
können wir festhalten dass künstliche
intelligenz auch ein passives phänomen
ist wie ich generell sagte zur
digitalisierung künstliche intelligenz
immer mehr teil unserer lebenswelt
sie trinken alle möglichen bereich vor
wie die digitalisierung so auch die ki
die darauf reagiert der begriff der
mensch-maschine-interaktion scheint
dafür nicht mehr angemessen dass
einschalten also warum weil wir der ki
nicht mehr wie ein objekt
gegenüberstehen sondern die ki die
fließt ein die prozesse in unseren
alltag
sicherlich zeigt sie sich vor allem an
maschinen aber wie ist es wenn ich denn
jetzt hier
eine smart watch am handgelenk habe und
die mit mir kommuniziert oder die meine
interessen auch exemplifiziert und mir
irgendwie informationen liefert die
maßgeschneidert sind da würde ich nicht
mehr unbedingt davon einer maschine
denken wieso ein
künstliches objekten ich gehe mit ihr
eine größere einheit ein also ich halte
hier immer noch ein bisschen zu viel
trennung
enthalten in dieser begriff mensch
maschine interaktion
es ist doch nahtlos hat dass das ein
entscheidendes sein es wird immer mehr
teil der lebenswelt und da ist
mensch-maschine-interaktion fast schon
zu sehr getrennt gedacht wie subjekt und
objekt
wir sollten kann ihn nicht dem sinne
eines objekts oder objekts denken
scheint mir sondern als prozess und
intelligenz leist also was sicherlich
kann ist
intel
intelligente akte zu manifestieren
natürlich kann man sich jetzt immer
fragen wenn man von aktien spricht dann
muss es doch ein subjekt geben was diese
akte
hervor bringt diese intelligenzen
leistung lässt sich in unserer
lebenswelt integrieren und mit anderen
menschlichen operationen vernetzen also
meint der durch die weg von diesen
subjekten vermeintlichen subjekten oder
objekten insel der leistung zu den
prozessen und prozesse sind prinzipiell
ablösbar und
modularen andere prozesse anschließbar
und eben auch ein menschliche
operationen und jetzt kann man eben die
ethik künstlicher intelligenz sehr gut
verstehen im sinne eines etwas also sie
nicht eine lebensform
künstlichen genc zeigt sich am ende an
der fähigkeit und der frage wie
angemessen sie als leistung in unsere
lebensweltliche kontext integriert
werden kann und sie kann es eben nicht
wenn wir sie uns alles ein supercomputer
vorstellen der uns irgendwie
gegenübersteht da wird er immer mit
künstlichen grenzen weil sein objekt
sichtbar tisch im sinne der lebensform
der lebenswelt ist dann ki angemessen
verstanden wenn wir sie nahtlos
integrieren können in ganz verschiedene
prozesse also es hat was von hilfsmittel
aber es ist eben nicht wieder nur so ein
bloßes objekt werden messe sondern es
steht mit uns in einer wechselwirkung
darauf gehe ich jetzt gleich noch mehr
ein
also künstliche intelligenz könnte so
verstanden werden dass sie zur
erweiterung des virtuellen raumes
handlungsrahmens beitritt wir hatten
schon das internet als einen solchen
virtuellen raum bestimmt und so glaube
ich können wir auch künstliche
intelligenz verstehen ich hab da mal ein
begriff entwickelt inter objektivität es
scheint mir ganz
angemessen zu sein für künstliche
intelligenz erklärt gleichwertig
dahintersteht künstliche neuronale netze
wir konzentrieren uns jetzt nur auf
künstliche neuronale netze die operieren
mit und auf gewaltigen datenmengen
erding sie mal an die per dieses
übersetzungsprogramm was wirklich ganz
hervorragend ist und erstaunliche
ergebnisse zeigt und es diese ergebnisse
dieser übersetzungsleistungen sind
wieder leistungen die per würde ich nie
als ein subjekt anziehen ich gehe auf
eine homepage und blickt da was rein
dass es kein subjekt zum hier geht es um
leistungen und diese leistung
übersetzungsleistung die es nur möglich
weil ganz gewaltige datenmengen diesem
programm zugrunde liegen und es
entscheidend ist jetzt dass selbst
unsere menschlichen leistungen in diese
datenmengen eingehen wir menschen
stellen die datenbasis zur verfügung auf
der dann die künstliche neuronale netze
lernen können aber das lernen ist nichts
was uns entfernt steht sind das lernen
ist immer ein lernen mit uns weil wir ja
die datenbasis auch liefern indem wir
zum beispiel suchanfragen im internet
eingeben indem wir die texte ins
internet einspeisen auf diesen texten
basiert ja auf dieser großen datenbasis
von linguee kennen sie sicherlich
das heißt menschliche leistung und kann
die leistung interferieren sie stehen in
wechselwirkung und ich haben sie in
einer mensch-maschine-interaktion wo man
sich wirklich wie so ein anderes objekt
oder ok banaler im sinne dieser
datenbasis auf die dekade zurück greift
in der objektivität ist ein begriff den
ich jetzt geprägt habe der bedeutet ein
kontext schon gründen und zielen der
durch die weiter vernetzt und verstärkt
wird das internet wird so immer so
weniger zu einem netz von bloßen
information als zuletzt von gründen also
von zielen von zwecken von handlungen
letztendlich und absichten und diese
absichten die wir natürlich immer zur
verfügungstellung die wir einspeisen die
können durch carney weiter verstärkt
werden oder erweitert gilt grundsätzlich
das heißt künstliche neuronale netze
müssen immer von außen ein ziel
vorgesetzt bekommen
sie sind nur hypothetisch autonomen
kathrin horn spricht hier von einer
minimalen autonomie da würde ich recht
geben aber hier stellt sich dann die
frage was ist jetzt minimal ich würde
vorschlagen es ist das hypothetische
hypothetisch bedeutet nur unter einer
bedingung sind sich autonom nämlich
unter einer bedingung oder einem ziel
das sie von außen vorgesetzt bekommen
also das system muss immer ein ziel
vorgesetzt bekommen auf das hin ist
agiert wenn es kein ziel hat kann die
motivation von außen dann wird es auch
selbst nicht tätig werden und das
scheint mir eben gerade die form von
autonomie zu sein wenn man überhaupt von
autonomie sprechen möchte die künstliche
neuronale netze bis jetzt menschliches
objekte geben die ziele dieses system
vor ohne diese ziele werden sie nie
tätig oder auch nie sinnvoll handeln
können
jetzt stellen sich einige probleme durch
den einsatz künstlicher intelligenz
nämlich zum einen die verantwortungs
zuschreibung die wird durch cani immer
schwieriger zum beispiel kann man sich
jetzt fragen wer trägt die verantwortung
wenn ein autonomes fahrzeug einen unfall
baut
die hersteller der kamin
die nutzer oder die künstliche
intelligenz selbst kann man dem auto ein
schuldvorwurf machen sinnvollerweise
darüber müssen wir jetzt diskutieren
nachher wer ist schuld weil die nutzer
sind auch möglich die not seiner nutzer
weil deren fahrverhalten ja immer auch
als datenbasis in dieses selbstlernende
namen netz einfließt wir haben ja
gesehen es gibt eine wechselwirkung
dh die hersteller die nutzen immer daten
und die daten die stammen natürlich von
uns allen menschen sofern wir irgendwie
damit einer verbindung stehen das heißt
man kann es nicht mehr so genau zu
schreiben diese schuld die verantwortung
dann wird schwieriger deswegen meinen
pdk als erweiterung unseres virtuellen
handlungsspielraums zu verstehen zur
virtuellen hand und sind sie viel
vernetzter als es unsere physischen
handlung sind und deswegen ist eben auch
die frage nach der verantwortung
zuschreibung von cani ebenfalls viel
komplexer jetzt kann man diskutieren ob
es dann wenn du nicht mehr individuelle
personen sind wie wir menschen sind
kollektive personen sind also verbünde
von personen netzwerke oder unternehmen
die am ende dann wenn es darum geht die
verantwortung tragen also wird immer
schwieriger einen bloßen individuum
welche schuld zuzuschreiben diesem
vernetzten raum der durch künstliche
lebens weiter verstärkt wird ja das
waren so ein paar thesen
und in der nächsten sitzung geht es
wieder um künstliche intelligenz und
robotik diesmal befassen wir uns mit dem
thema augmented
intelligence also die erweiterung der
intelligenz leistung anbietet engelbart
vorgeschlagen hat die mir sehr plausibel
erscheinen die viele probleme zu lösen
vermag und wir wollen jetzt diskutieren
über zwei
fragen nämlich einmal in wie vielen
stillen künstliche systeme ein
moralisches problem dar und die zweite
frage ist inwiefern
künstliche systeme als autonom und
intelligent bezeichnet werden eine
dritte frage die auch noch spannend wäre
die wir am rande behandelt worden ist
die wer trägt eigentlich die
verantwortung für das was künstliche
neuronale zu produzieren oder zum
beispiel autonome fahrzeuge verursachen
wer trägt die verantwortung
erstens die programmiererin
programmierer
das unternehmen wir nutzerinnen und
nutzer die datenbasis zur verfügung
stellen oder am ende doch dieses gefährt
selbst darüber wollen wir jetzt gleich
diskutieren